[Music]
hardest part of making the customer the
focus is actually getting the visibility
the visibility of every step of the way
to figure out how you can improve that
set of customer service well what if you
could use technologies that would
actually give you that visibility so
that you could trace that experience end
to end identify the opportunities for
improvement and then think about how you
can realize that to your end customer
we've seen a certain set of capabilities
that become core components of every
digital process automation strategy
three key areas
so first is organizations that are
really being successful are going
through a process of learning that
process of learning is really all about
this idea of collaborative discovery how
do we unlock the hidden knowledge in the
organization and use that to understand
how we get from point A to point Z and
if we could then learn what these new
opportunities for innovation is we could
be more focused with our scarce
resources that I know you all face to
make sure that we have the biggest
impact for where those people spend
their time now that collaborative
discovery feeds into a critical
component which is if you've learned
something it means nothing if you
obviously can't put it into action and
so organizations today are trying to
figure out how when they unlock this
insight they figure out how to turn that
into something that's actionable by the
people in their organization in every
customer service engagement that's
actionable in the way that they go and
create the infrastructure to support it
and so we think about that as a problem
around actionable insights it's being
able to use the knowledge the data in
your organization to make your people
and your business more effective now
there's tons of amazing new technology
that's coming to bear to go and help
with that but again this key focus is
putting data at the center of everything
you do and thinking about how you can
able your people to leverage that data
to their advantage lastly is getting
consistency across your organization so
the question is how do you actually go
and achieve consistency at every single
one of those touch points so you're
always putting your best foot forward at
any given time well that's really hard
to do
unless you have a set of technology that
really enables you to digitize your
business and achieve that consistency by
automating the interactions that could
be error-prone thinking about how to
capture key decisions being made in your
organization and embedding that into
your infrastructure so people aren't
making human mistakes on a regular basis
and really thinking about what a tale
takes to bring that across your
organization at scale so what we found
as part of that is we've seen that a
couple of key capabilities in each one
of these areas are the critical
foundation for success in each one of
these different areas if you're thinking
about unlocking the knowledge in your
organization organizations are trying to
figure out the latent hidden processes
what is it that my organization does
what's the essence of what I do and then
thinking about the key decisions think
about all the knowledge that's stored in
people's heads that could only be
unlocked encoded into systems and used
to build up that knowledgebase
now what they really want to do is then
figure out how to take those things and
lay out the blueprint the essence of
what their business does and that's
where the automation part comes in
because if I can take whatever might be
a hundred step process and ensure that I
could reduce the errors in a couple of
those deaths automate them and figure
out the highest point of value for
humans then that's a great opportunity
to achieve consistency and help my
business to ultimately scale and serve
more customers but then the question is
what do I do with the people so I still
have people that are the lifeblood of my
business those are the people that are
on the front lines working with my
customers working with partners they're
taking the insights to figure out where
do I invest next what is the next great
product and service that I can offer and
what those people need to be able to do
is put in context all this great
business information and use that at
every single point what do I mean by
every single point well it's not someone
who's sitting in the back office
somewhere there was a great term called
armchair science for those of you the
love science the armchair scientist was
someone that theorized way back in their
armchair but never actually got out into
the real world that's probably not the
best formula that I could recommend for
your business the best opportunity is to
take the data in your systems get it in
the hands of the frontline people that
are interacting with your customers and
partner on a daily basis and to use that
information to their advantage
we see a huge opportunity to help the
next generation of workforce leverage
this set of digital data to their
advantage they do that by leveraging
real-time insights so being able to use
that data and synthesize it at
incredible speed and we're going to look
at a new area actually where people are
thinking about things like assistance to
help them become more productive to
remove the minutiae of things that could
be automated and help them focus on what
the value
[Music]